the launch of a new Coal Mine in
Australia has divided the
country
more no more we have to take stronger
action Civil Disobedience they are over
here pleading with our governments not
to build new coal mines we have a
responsibility to them an energy giant
seeks to generate electricity in India
and create jobs across
Australia the opportunity is to feed the
the very very best call to those plants
we have an industry to be super proud of
adani is a revolution for us in central
Queensland because it's going to give
our job
opportuni but some fear the impact on
Australia's natural resources I'm
government is destroying the Great
Barrier
e we've lost about half of all the
corals of the great
B with communities bracing for impact in
their neighborhoods
yeah that's a water bomber he's gone
back to the airport to refill cuz
there's a fire still going over the back
there in 30 years when we've got raging
bush fires our waterers running out we
can't grow crops
anymore can the Australian government
fight the realities of climate change
we're getting more Cyclones we're
getting our monsal events and climate
change is a big
issue
[Music]
from doing what we did whether we lost
in the court or whether we
[Music]
lost
Def
Queensland
Australia suburbs in the Southeastern
tip of the country are engulfed in
bushfires catastrophic hot drought-like
conditions with wind speed of 90 M an
hour the fires spread
fast people are evacuated to safety
while more than 20 homes are burnt to
ashes
Rescue Services use aerial bombers to D
the fires now spread over 4,200
Acres an emergency is declared in vast
sedes of
Queensland in May 2019 65% of Queensland
was declared to be in drought water
supplies for farms and homes are running
dry
we traveled to Stan Thorp a Suburban
Town 2 hours from Brisbane to
investigate the impact of this heat
wave behind a number of homes in those
two locations
of away that's James moris from the New
South Wales rural fire service giving us
the latest update on
those the severity of dwindling Water
Supplies can be gauged by the signboards
that welcome
us
as we arrive firefighters leave to douse
raging fires
nearby Stop's community meeting is
called local police and the mayor have
urgent announcements exclusion zones and
I can't stress enough they are exclusion
zones for safety reasons we've got trees
that have been burnt out in those dry
root systems that could easily fall over
on pass there's power lines down you can
see the direction the wind was going and
did it with speed and with um ferocious
climes the residents are holed up inside
the center unsure if their homes have
survived the
blaze while outside water bombing
continues as fires briefly subside
70-year-old old car Stratford is allowed
back into her
home this was all Al light on Friday
night have watched all this burn and
that house that's up the top there is
called the eagle nest and I'm surprised
the eagle nest escaped cuz that was just
burning they had to call the firies back
there yesterday to put some out stuff
out but it got up to there it stopped
there so there must have been a heap of
fies here see that brown thing behind
those rocks that's melted there's a
little car that's a water tank it's
melted the top of it melted and there's
water in it that's how that's how hot
the fire
was car's home miraculously survived the
fire stopped a few meters from where she
lives us to be to when you're faced with
not having a home to come back with and
that's the thing that's still getting to
me how lucky I am that my home survived
I've got my late husband's voice on that
that's only thing I've got of hearing in
talk and that was when it snowed here on
the 17th of August
2015 that's when
snowed they evacuated those people out
of there the hardest thing is when you
get the knock on the door you know it's
coming from the police saying get out
and I said oh yeah I'll get I've I've
got everything packed everything ready
and he said well make sure you
go Stop's remaining water supply is
being sacrificed for fire
in well the fact that we've been in
drought up here for so long we having a
decent rain
for oh good two years now um we've had
spasmodic rain our dam if you go have a
look at Stone King Dam um that'll shock
you cuz that's really shocking out there
we're on severe water restrictions we'll
be out of water at the town here by
December and I don't know if they're
using the water from our dam out there
to fill F fire bombers for this don't
know where they're getting the water
from the fires have shattered
livelihoods animal habitats water
supplies and
agriculture according to the climate
Council of Australia economic loss due
to reduced agricultural productivity is
projected to exceed $19 billion by
2030 211 billion by5
50 and 4 trillion by
[Music]
2100 reusing water has now become the
only way to survive the drought in many
parts of the country s many bath water
in there cuz I save
that right and then I use my bucket that
I got there iny washing machine I'll
have to give that a rinse out this
there's all Ash inside there from the
fire from the ash that come through so I
bucket it with that bucket in there
Wash Me clothes in it hang it out then
put it out into the bucket and then it
goes on what plants I've got to keep
alive that's sing way your water plants
not let outside water your plants
there's no doubt the climate is evolving
it is
changing but I know that we're getting a
few degrees warmer each year you know
we' we've noticed a big increase in the
in in the global
warming but I don't know how you stop
that um there's something definitely
happening with the Earth
the stateof the climate 2018 report for
Australia reveals a land surface
temperature increase of 1°
C that's led to hot dry conditions
perfect for
bushfires the science was saying then
that if we keep putting carbon dioxide
and methane into the atmosphere the
temperature will steadily increase there
will be more frequent extremes more very
hot days days there'll be changes to
rainfall patterns so the science was
saying 30 years ago that Perth Adelaide
Melbourne the southern cities of
Australia would get drier and that's all
happened already Australia is ranked the
seventh highest carbon emitter per
capita one big reason Coal Fired power
plants coal provides fuel for about 70%
of electricity production in Australia a
majority of these plants located in the
state of
Queensland the state has a historical
relationship with coal mining began here
in the 18th
century behind most coal mining
operations lay years of struggle and
toil this coal earned royalties for the
Queensland government and sparked
Development Across the
country but today the region is a shadow
of past with coal jobs lost to
automation still coal production
continues to grow to feed a hungry
Market
abroad now instead of reducing
Australia's carbon footprint the
Queensland Premier has promised to open
new coal mines in her State it's part of
Anastasia palach's plan to create
thousands of new
jobs but at what price
[Music]
Australia is the world's largest
exporter of coal a commodity that's
aided the rise in temperatures
worldwide Coal Fired electricity
generation accounted for 30% of global
CO2 emissions according to the
International Energy agency resulting in
record temperatures of 40° C in
Australia leaving the residents of
stanthorne desperate for
[Music]
water as Rescue Services scramble to
save lives queensland's Premier calls
for an emergency press
[Music]
conference so we have uh a number of
families at the moment that are actually
going through um some really traumatic
times so we are in the process C of
trying to reach those families we
understand that they're all safe but
they will be going through um a lot of
grief at the moment and I know that our
community will pull together and uh
definitely make sure that they get back
on their feet uh Premier we're filming a
documentary from Singapore from channel
news Asia just wanted to get a comment
from you about uh the increasing number
of coal mines resulting in Rising
temperatures do you feel that the this
is the direct impact of that well we do
know that climate change has a big
impact we knew that um from we're
getting more Cyclones we're getting
monsoonal events and climate change is a
big issue that everyone signs up to in
terms of keeping with the Paris
treaty but the latest addition to
queensland's Coal industry has incensed
thousands of anti-al protesters across
the country no more coal no more
coal after the break we investigate the
politics of coal in Australia
2third of extreme weather events in the
last 20 years were caused by human
activities the Paris agreement signed in
2016 aimed to curb emissions to minimize
temperature rise by
1.5° if current trends continue the
world is likely to pass the 1.5° C Mark
between 2030 and
2052 unless it finds a way to reach net
zero
emissions amid this alarming situation
the state of Queensland announced new
coal mines to boost the economy and
create
jobs that's when Indian billionaire GTA
madani announced plans to build a mine
at carmichel a rural Outpost in the
Australian
Outback at the time carmichel was to
excavate 60 million tons of coal a year
that figure has since been held
up in effect what we're building now is
a 10 million ton perm Coal Mine we just
one of 125 operating coal mines in
Australia we'll be building 200 km of
Greenfield rail construction to T at the
existing Network so combined that will
represent around uh $2 billion
Australian investment uh to be able to
get us into production and we'll see
that coming online in
2021 the main would be located on the
Galilee
Basin 160 km Northwest of Clermont it
will also feature a rail line connecting
the mine to the Abott Point
Terminal the opening of the carmichel
mine is expected to attract more
investments in the mining sector which
activists say would increase Greenhouse
emissions that trap heat and make the
planet
warmer roughly 30% of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions came from
electricity production from coal and gas
in
Australia's mining sector once the
backbone of the economy is in a Long
protracted
slump I think a lot more businesses are
going to close which a lot have already
closed haven't they D they've had to
close the doors because there's no
people in the town people have to move
away because there is nothing here you
know um so the younger generation's got
no future yeah that's right the younger
generation of Bowen they've got nothing
what do they turn to look around I mean
town's dead completely completely dead
and uh the town needs employment real
bad there's nothing here for the younger
generation they will leave
town adani announced thousands of jobs
to be created over the next few years a
prospect much welcomed by the mining
Community Pro ad movement was centered
around jobs uh jobs for the community
um clemont's a very strong mining town I
think it was founded uh on copper mining
back in the 1800s and obviously then
gold and the people of clemont following
the investment and in town um and the
ability for those people to gain jobs um
was very proad I think I I believe that
mining is important I I don't think that
it's sustainable to think that we can go
straight from calf power to natural
resources like wind or solar but I think
they should work hand in
hand number of people locally uh work in
the morning industry so a lot of them
are quite Keen I believe to get more
jobs going um in that
area unemployment here hovers above
9% compared to around 6% in Queensland
as a
whole that's why Bruce headage is busy
promoting the adani
mine he started the go adani
campaign it's going to generate a lot of
job opportunities for Central Queensland
the Queensland government last year
received 3.8 billion in Coal royalties
from from from coal mines throughout
this state $3.8
billion uh next year the Queensland
government will spend $3.9 billion on
interest interest on loans now the
opponents of adani and coal are asking
us as a community to stop
coal exports stop the royalties coming
through I would love someone to tell me
where the $3.8 billion is going to come
from for a town to void of jobs it's a
polarizing question of unemployment
versus the
environment there are questions about
whether or not the mine will pay
appropriate Roy roties or any royalties
to our state government and uh huge
concerns about the fact that there won't
be that many jobs provided and that the
company has
effectively massively exaggerating uh
exaggerated the jobs that they say it
would it would
provide adani's initial promise of
thousands of new jobs was challenged by
a court
testimony an affidavit alleged that
adani mining's billion dooll carai coal
project would have 483 full-time
equivalent jobs while Queensland as a
whole would have
1,26 full-time equivalent
jobs we'll see over 1,500 uh direct jobs
created during the ramp up and
construction for the mine and Rail and a
further 6,750 indirect jobs so in total
what we're talking about is 8,250 jobs
invest injected into the Australian
economy in particular in Regional
Queensland and and specifically areas
that have typically got high levels of
unemployment and we're talking about
areas that have approached close to 10%
levels of unemployment so the project
certainly very important for Australia
and for Queensland and Regional
Queensland as it relates to
jobs jobs aside TV journalist Mark
willsy has news that's far less
hopeful he tracked developments on adani
mining
elsewhere the company was charged in
Zambia with polluting a major river and
convicted um under Australian law if you
um have any convictions or issues
involving Mining and you're in charge
you have to declare that that was not
declared by this particular adani
executive at the time and that
culminated recently with adani being
charged and it's going to be prosecuted
for supplying false and misleading
information to the state government here
in
Queensland the state of Queensland
imposed hundreds of environmental
conditions for the k mine to adhere
to particular attention was paid to
adani's surface water use and the mine's
proximity to the Great artisian
Basin the Great artisian Basin is the
biggest underwater resource in the world
stretching over 1.7 million square
km it is 3,000 M deep in places and is
estimated to contain 65,000 cubic km of
groundwater the Basin provides the only
source of fresh water to much of Inland
Australia underground coal mines rely on
water to reduce the risk of fires or
explosions by using it to cool The
Cutting surfaces of mining equipment and
prevent cold dust from Catching
Fire so we know about water being very
precious the adani mine would suck up as
much water as the rest of the users in
the whole catchment and they don't have
to pay as much for it because our state
laws are very LAX and give a whole lot
of freebies to mining companies for
reasons that we can go into later mostly
because they make generous donations to
both sides of politics we will not be
extracting water from the Great iian
Basin we don't have any plans we don't
have any authorities or we don't have
any approvals to extract water from the
Great iian Basin there are instances
where we'll have to extract groundw
simply to be able to make allow mining
to be undertaken safely so it's simply
for safety reasons not for water
extraction reasons and outside of that
all of our water will be sourced uh from
surface
sources Tom CS a former Queensland water
Chief estimates the mine may tap on a
substantial amount of the state's Water
Resources when ad starts to extract coal
and uh intercepts the Great artisian
Basin acas water will flow out of those
aquifers into the mine pits and adani
are allowed to extract unlimited volumes
of water out of those mine pits to keep
their mining Operation Safe ad an there
the modeled extraction of water over the
life of the mine is 270 gigal that is
equivalent to around about 55% of Sydney
Harbor Animal grazers like Bruce Curry
rely on the Great artisian Basin for
their water supplies he lives in
speculation a rural Outpost in the
Australian
Outback people can't exist without water
if you want to know what I'm talking
about turn your water supply off for 2
days and try and survive regardless of
where you are because what's happening
here they're turning our water off for
perpetuity when they destroy it it's
gone
forever along with wife fette the
curries have been running this farmland
for Generations this is the coal seam
they they want to dig out it's The Deco
seam this is where we draw our water
from which is the clima sandstone and
that is part of the feed into the Great
artisian Basin the only thing is once
they they mine that coal seam out they
have a process called long wall Mining
and what it does is once the coal comes
out they just collapse all the St above
it so what that'll do it'll drain that
come Sandstone so basically it it'll
destroy our water supply and it'll
destroy part of the feed into the Great
artisian Basin and uh which will impact
on the Integrity of the Great artisian
Basin Bruce's worries about destroyed
Water Supplies inspired him to go in a
fact-f finding Walkabout
overseas he wanted to see what the
future of speculation might look like
way out in
India I went to India few years ago to
actually have a look at the uh diny
operation and to talk to my main concern
was to talk to communities and Farmers
over in that area and um get a a good
understanding of the company that would
be coming when I was in India we went to
uh the adani special economics arm up
there in the Gulf of catch and I spoke
to fisherman there and they highlighted
to me there the pressures and the the uh
impacts that they're suffering because
the tar as well as the Adonis have built
a power station there they actually
released their hot water out into the
ocean and which kills the um juvenile
fish fish eggs and has a big impact on
the the fishing communities that are
trying to survive on that source of
income they're also not doing anything
about the fly ash that's coming out of
their smoke there the stacks of the
power station and that fly ash is going
across Farmers lands
Bruce is unsure if similar damage to the
great Arian Basin is
reversible once the mine starts and the
dewatering
starts uh whether that their findings
are accurate or not they cannot repair
the damage and the water is mined
forever it's lost for
perpetuity regardless of how big their
mistake is they cannot Rectify it they
cannot correct it and the impact is is
there for
perpetuity as the climate gets hotter
and drier water is even more
precious Farmers like Bruce want their
groundwater to be protected from any
damage it's a shame that more people
aren't aware of what the great artisian
basin's all about it's you know one of
the biggest freshw underground freshwat
sources in the world and it's not
polluted it's not contaminated
it's environmental
terrorism the money we've made and the
life we've lived on
spe and to think that they could just
through the flick of a
pen take that away from
us it's not fair and it's not right like
when you went to India to have a look at
those poor Farms over there I don't
begin to understand half that has a
affected their
family what would we
[Music]
do after a prolonged legal battle the
adani carmichel mine has received the
environmental clearances it
needs but the opposition to its
construction
continues after the break we go
underwater to investigate the impact of
rising greenhouse gases on the Great
Barrier Reef
there's parts of the Great Bay reef
where you can uh drive on a boat or or
Swim for kilometers without seeing a
living
Coral Indian energy giant adani wants to
mine Australian coal planning to export
it back to
India adani is the largest private
thermal power producer in India with an
installed capacity of more than 12,000
megaw but they're ramping up production
in India adani stands to gain from the
rising need for power in developing
South Asia to fill the Gap in Supply
it's looking at Australian
coal Coal will be shipped through Abbott
Point Port operations it's been
operating for over 35 years in an
environmentally responsible way there's
thousands of ship movements through the
Great Barrier Reef every year so the
prospect that the shipment of our coal
for the Great Barrier Reef is going to
have a direct impact on the reef is just
a
falsehood to export this call adani
signed a 99-year lease with abot Point
Terminal in
2011 the deal cost adani roughly 2
billion Australian dollars a few years
back there was a plan for massive
expansion of ports in the great barri
reef and there's basically six big ports
already and there was a hope by industry
um with a hand being held by government
to expand those ports to ship more coal
out and more liquefied natural gas out
through the Great Barrier Reef to World
Export markets now the problem with
making ports um bigger and deeper is
that it requires a huge amount of
dredging so the huge impacts from that
dredging were um a very very big concern
to Marine
scius the developments surrounding
Abbott Point Port are being keenly
watched by Coral expert Charlie
Veron that's because of Aid Point's
close proximity to the Great Barrier
Reef Marine
Park the Great Barrier Reef is the
world's largest coral reef system
composed of over 2,900 individual reefs
large enough that it can be seen from
outer
space this is the world's biggest single
structure made by living
organisms
reefs occupy just 1% of the world's
marine environment but they provide a
home to a quarter of all marine species
including unique fish Turtles and
algae a large part of the reef is
protected by the Great Barrier Reef
Marine
Park which helps to limit the impact of
human use such as fishing and
tourism The Reef has lost more than half
its Coral cover since
1985 high temperatures cause Mass Coral
bleaching due to warm ocean
waters a coral reef is a very
competitive environment everything
competes with everything else all the
time so corals have got this symbiosis
with the algae and that produces food
and oxygen but if you raise the
temperature just above the absolute
temperature tolerance that the corals
have the algae produce too much ox
oxygen and that kills
them we head out to investigate the
effects of rising temperatures on the
Great Barrier
Reef Charlie Von is out to collect
evidence he's hoping the remaining Reef
might be spared from rising
temperatures there's parts of the Great
Bay reef where you can uh drive on a
boat or or Swim for kilometers without
seeing a living Coral so the worst
affected is total death of the whole
reef and we see that in a few reefs uh
but the majority of reefs of the great B
have not been wiped out by any means but
they have been quite severely
damaged reefs protect coastlines from
flooding during extreme storms which is
why saving corals is critical
[Music]
as the Seas warm and they're warming
gradually every year the the increase
that threatens corals warms
incrementally just each year it gets
more and more threatening and whether
that kills the coral or not depends on
the amount of time it exposed to these
maximum conditions maximum temperature
conditions that varies in patches all
over the ocean surface and it but it is
increasing year by year and that will
continue Charlie is now retired but has
spent his life raising awareness of
coral
bleaching the other is um direct lying
direct telling of Lies by politicians
when for example um uh politicians say
that Australia is meeting all its
obligations under the Kyoto Under Paris
agreement um Australia is going
absolutely nowhere near meeting its
obligations now it is not possible for a
politician to to not know the truth
because scientists know the truth
scientists tell the politicians it's all
in publications of all different levels
so if you want to say we are meeting our
obligations under all these uh treaties
that have happened um you are not
telling the truth and again that's
political a report C by the government's
Australian Institute of Marine Science
wasn't
encouraging Rising water temperatures
are likely to cause more Coral bleaching
producing irreversible damage to the
reef scientists expect the coral May
recover over the next 5 to 10 years but
only if another Mass bleaching event
doesn't occur during that
time
that's unlikely given the current
trajectory of climate
change in 2015 Australia Institute put
the carmichel M's expected emissions
over the next 30 years into perspective
it believes the annual carbon emissions
of this single coal mine would be three
times the average annual emissions from
New
Delhi double those from
Tokyo six times that of
Amsterdam and 20% more than New York
City if the mine produces 40 megatons
per
year adding more carbon dioxide from
mines can potentially threaten thousands
of animal species that rely on the reef
not to mention the $6.4 billion in
tourism revenue and 64,000 full-time
jobs the Great Barrier Reef provides to
Australia tourism operator linday
Simpson is concerned about her
livelihood her boat tours serve
International tourists on a daily
basis if we add more mins to that we are
looking at a reef that's already under
terrible threat we're looking at 70,000
people earning their money from tourism
who won't have anywhere to take anyone
to look at and I mean I've had
laughingly heard people say there
something called disaster
tourism she decided to investigate adani
by traveling to India on her own and
ended up writing a
book he was going to bring jobs to
everyone so he was going to make it all
good again and give lots of work now we
all know 2% of the Australia's Workforce
work in mines and if you think about
that it's an automated industry if we
look at how many of these people are
going to get jobs ad Dow promised in
India he was going to give all these
jobs to locals he then imported workers
from Arisa and all these other places he
did not give the locals jobs he did for
the first year and there is evidence
he's giving work now that work is not
going to be there and if you look at in
terms of long-term work 1,300 workers is
what he was talking about versus 70,000
in tourism and those workers are only
going to be fly in fly out
the coal mine has also sparked the
native title
movement every mining project in this
country it tends to be out in um remote
country and a lot of that country is
traditional Aboriginal country and under
Australian law um Aboriginal people from
those areas can claim what they call
native title and that's a form of
guardianship over these lands now no one
has taken guardianship over that land
but there is an Aboriginal group there
that wants to do that that and they can
legitimately apply to the courts to do
that as a leader of the wangan and jagal
lingu Native people who own this land
Adrian baragua took adani to court
according to him the carmichel coal mine
can harm around 30,000 hectares of his
community's traditional
lands eventually the Court ruled in
favor of adani Australia who are now
seeking $600,000 in court costs which
would bankrupt Bur
G Adrien and his clan have now been
barred from entering their own lands
this always was original land this
always was first nation's Sovereign land
because of our culture and how we
maintain our culture and we're not going
anyway it's always going to be abigal
land it's always going to be our
land and if they can if they want if
they want to come out here and try to
move us and move our sacred site then uh
they will be criticized this country
will be screwed scrutinized over their
treatment of abigal people the Wang and
jagal lingu people will no longer stand
for this bullying tactic from adani or
from any government in this
country but Adrian's resistance sparked
a people's movement across Australia the
stop adani
movement they are over here pleading
with our governments not to build new
coal mines we have a responsibility to
them and to our children to have a safe
future for them to live in
the opposition to adani's kichel M has
sparked a Grassroots environmental
movement across
Australia a loose group of environmental
activists students and common folk
coming together to pressurize adani to
stop the
mine
some of them have gathered at Camp bin
it's called the stop adani
movement we've been given exclusive
access to the camp after much
deliberation and background
checks 23-year-old Amy Booth used to
live in Victoria but decided to join the
stop adani movement in the Australian
Outback people are going to be displaced
by the climate crisis
so I felt that me working um in the city
taking sort of doing business as usual
working 9 to 5 just isn't where I want
to be right now we have a moral
obligation to to act and to stop this
mine and to stop other environmental
problems going ahead um so I'm I'm
willing to put my life on hold for the
moment to do what I can to stop projects
like this from going ahead because this
isn't just
about this particular area every project
that is a fossil fuel project is adding
to CO2 in the atmosphere and that
affects the entire
Globe protesters like ay believe that if
built a Dan's carmichel mine will add
billions of tons of carbon pollution to
our atmosphere
in that context it is criminally
irresponsible to be proposing the
opening of new coal mines or new Coal
Fired power stations and the adani case
is a particularly important one because
that would not just be a significant
Coal Mine in itself it would potentially
open up the whole Galilee Basin as a new
coal Province and there are five or six
other possible coal mines in the
pipeline that would be more likely to go
ahead if a Dan started because the
infrastructure for getting the coal to
Port uh for managing water and energy
and infrastructure would be there and
that would reduce the startup cost of
other coal mines and that's why adani
has become a really symbolic issue in
Australia these anti-al activists are
now taking a more Hands-On position by
physically blocking coal trains mines
and machines a strategy now commonly
known as a
lockdown on 22nd July 2019 protesters
set up a blockade outside the Abott
Point
Port about 20 members of the
Environmental Group gathered outside the
port entrance at 7:00
a.m. what are we here for this footage
was filmed by Amy as a co-pro 22 y- old
Emily Star and 20-year-old Matilda
hessin locked themselves to a concrete
Barrel we wanted to start acting to show
that we weren't going to let we weren't
going to sit by and let this just
happen um so we locked on in terms of we
had our arms clipped onto this um little
bar inside a
Barrel that was filled with cement and
then there was a PVC tube that our arms
would go down and be clipped
onto they stopped the supply of coal for
hours that's when the Queensland police
stepped
in as tension mounted a French
television crew filmed the action from
the
side I was willing to be arrested which
I was because a shortterm inconvenience
of being arrested and being given a fine
is okay with me because the long-term
benefit of stopping this mine from going
ahead will be
amazing Amy continued filming events
that
day of
them the journalists and activists are
detained and charged with trespassing on
the railway
line the French crew were later released
after global condemnation grew but
they've since been barred from filming
anywhere close to the mine they were
embarrassed they think that that was a
mistake what the officers did up there
and I know from the police commissioner
down that was why the the charges were
dropped so it was some overzealous
police policing by those police officers
are up up
there Emily and Matilda are now facing a
court hearing at
Bowen uncertain if they'll be allowed
back into Camp
bin we're hoping that no curve balls
will be thrown when we get in there but
it'll likely just be sort of well we're
hoping it'll be a fine with no like
restitution order against us but we're
not sure what it will be really
magistrates can do whatever they
like after an hour they come out of the
Court
I feel like he understood our passion as
well which I think was really important
I really liked hearing that he did
understand that even if he didn't
necessarily agree with it yeah
yeah I think that in Australia we have a
huge problem and in many places around
the world we have a huge problem where
the political systems are broken and
that's why we've come to do these kind
of actions because we feel like these
are the only sort of things that can put
enough pressure on political systems to
fundamentally change rather than just
sort of put a Band-Aid on the
issue where are the critical point in
history there's no doubt that in
ecological terms we're booked on the
Titanic we're heading for the iceberg
and there are still irresponsible people
both literally and metaphorically
throwing coal in the boilers as if they
wanted to get there
faster coal particulates pollution is
estimated to shorten 1 Million Lives
annually
worldwide one study even estimates
premature deaths arising from coal
related air pollution could be as high
as 52,000 people
worldwide but with solar and wind power
slowly creeping up there's been positive
change Coal's use has been on the
decline in Europe and the US AIT cheaper
alternatives adani Australia is
promoting solar power as a means to
bridge the gap between coal emissions
and the global push towards renewable
energy rugby run which has an initial
capacity of 65 megaw is located near
morar it's not a question of Renewables
or coal it's Renewables and coal and so
from our perspective we've already we've
got under over 2,385 megawatts under con
under operation uh in relation to solar
and we've got another 23 40 megaw
currently under construction of solar
capacity so in short uh you know we've
got in excess of 4,700 megaw of
Renewables capacity in our portfolio
that's a mixture of of Sol principally
solar but we've also got hybrid in there
as well including wind so we see that uh
moving forward in order to meet the
developing world's energy demand
requirements it's going to continue to
require underpinning Basel load cied
power generation in addition to
Renewables through the likes of solar
wind um hydro and so forth
many believe the solution to Australia's
cold dependence has to come from within
the political
sphere the Australian greens run on four
core values ecological
sustainability social justice Grassroots
democracy and peace and
nonviolence we were just sitting in
Parliament and the best thing about that
whole experience was that we could hear
you more than we can hear
them which is frankly what Parliament
should be about it should be about the
people's voice being
ref the greens have a plan to phase out
coal and create a jobs boom in the
renewable energy export
industry we have great economic
potential in clean energy here in
Queensland in Australia globally we know
that there's more jobs in Renewables we
know that um renewable energy can do the
job we've now got the battery storage
the solar thermal the ways of making
clean energy at 24/7 and dispatchable
there is no reason to not go down that
path and actually Safeguard
Humanity Australia's current bushire
season has taken 12 lives destroyed
millions of hect of land and wiped out
nearly 500 million animals with no signs
of rains or temperatures
subsiding stopping global warming will
require coordinated policy by national
state and local
governments and the development of
climate friendly energy policies that
are backed by politicians and activists
alike Before Time runs out and the
irreversible effects of climate change
impacts the very existence of
[Music]
humankind Brazil's Amazon rainforest is
being devastated by
fires many of the farmers think the
Amazon shouldn't exist a battle between
economic development and environmental
concerns it was planed fostered and
executed by the boson government with
thousands of miners invading the forests
to hunt for
gold nearly 10,000 square kilm of the
Amazon are destroyed in
2019 displacing hundreds of indigenous
communities pushing them to the
edge
they gr noise CNA investigates why the
lungs of the world are being
[Music]
lost
sa Pao
Brazil by 300 p.m. the city is smothered
by black clouds of
smoke scientists eventually discovered
for the
cause fires raging in the far north of
the country thousands of miles away in
the Amazon
[Music]
rainforest official figures show more
than 87,000 Amazonian fires are recorded
in Brazil in the first 8 months of
2019 an increase of 76% from 2018
these fires destroy 10,000 square kilm
of the Amazon in
2019 while the Brazilian government
fails to
[Music]
act the world responds with
outrage with criticism focused on newly
elected far-right president Jer
bolaro the Hat we know today was not not
happen by chance it was planed fostered
and executed by the bonaro government
this is the
true after bolsonaro's election Brazil's
environmental agencies had their budget
slashed his economic policies are
focused on developing the economy inside
the Amazon
rainforest at least of birds sell but
alam's investigation earthed a bigger
problem lack of implementation of
Brazil's Forest
laws what has happened the company looks
to theine I find two or three million
high if I use good lawyers I can stay
years and years and years without pay or
is more expensive to pay at same time we
receive the fine then
Roll and Roll and Roll again the fines
it's happen every
time from 1980 to 2019 penalties for
cutting trees down in protected areas
totaled $7 billion
US less than 4% of these fines were
collected corruption and the inability
to collect fines have encouraged more
violators to set up shop inside the
Amazon with hundreds of thousands of
dollars to be
made there's a lot of people working
with it there's the people from illegal
loging there's the people from AG
business there's the people linked to
Illegal gold mining for example there's
a people practicing Wildlife traffic
there's a lot of people working with
this chain of crimes in the Amazon their
first station is one of them
the cleared land is used to produce beef
and Agri
products a large portion of which is
exported to parts of
Asia people need to understand that we
are all responsible for this so even
people far away in Pakistan in China in
Australia are also help helping with
environment problems in the Amazon
because they are consumers they're
helping to consume product that are
coming from this
region worldwide forests still cover
about 30% of the planet but they're
disappearing at an alarming
rate between 1990 and 2016 the world
lost 1.3 million square km of forest
according to the World Bank that's an
area larger than South
Africa
[Music]
for
we arrive in the state of bar to
investigate the effects of the fires in
Northern
Brazil burnt down jungles now resemble a
war
[Music]
zone Erica banga is an environmental
scientist who's lived in the Amazon for
the last 10 years studying the
destructive force of the fires
here but what do we have um so the tube
that we put on the ground a mesh tube
which is 30 cm and on the ground
and The Roots grow inside the tube so
every 3 months we get the tube off the
ground put the soil in the sheet and
then we handpick all the roots for 1
hour and then we put the soil back in
the tube the mash tube back in the soil
and then it's going to saay for another
3 months so I can see in those 3 months
how many roots are produce how many
roots grow in there and then we can
estimate how much of the carbon it's
being allocated to the
[Music]
roots Erica takes us for a walk inside a
protected area to show us the impact of
fires on the
Amazon so this is one of the main
difference that you're going to see
between a burn forest and an unborn
Forest you can see that we're not seeing
many trees many big big thick trees that
we associate with Amazon just all very
thin fast growing
species the Amazon rainforest has 410
billion trees in this region
alone with a total of 76 billion tons of
carbon stored in
them if we were to Deforest the whole of
the Amazon basing that comprises nine
countries all the emissions that would
the from this forestation would be
equivalent of 100 Years of the US fossil
fuel emissions that's how much carbon
that Amazon store so it's a vital
component to fight climate change by
keeping the forest standing we are
locking all this carbon in the forest
and not putting back into the atmosphere
the study shows that take over 100 years
to recover the carbon stocks that were
present in this forest and we still
don't know how long it's going to take
for the biodiversity to
cover
animals are being affected
too it's believed that there are about 3
million different species of plant and
animal life in the
Amazon in the Amazon it's estimated that
there is
16,000 species of tree just in the
Brazilian part of the Amazon which is
60% of the whole Amazon we estimate to
be 11,000 species unfortunately I think
that within my lifetime if there's no
political will if we don't take strong
positions Damon is going to be
gone but president bolsonaro wants to
abolish protection for indigenous
lands his calls have been echoed by
miners who've put self-preservation
ahead of Environmental
Conservation after the break we meet
these miners who have invaded the Amazon
in search of
[Music]
gold Brazil is one of the biggest gold
producers in the
[Music]
world with output reported at 81 million
kg in
2018 but there is a new gold rush in
Brazil
today one fueled by Soaring unemployment
in regions inside the Amazon Rain
Forest they're invading public lands log
the trees do some gold mining and and
damage in these areas or do some fishing
and
hunting as the planet loses the Amazon
rainforest at a rapid Pace there are
miners on the other end of the equation
who are making increasing
gains locally known as Garen peros their
Rising incomes develop cities like
pesoto de ASU
located in metho state they are gold
producing hubs for Brazil's lucrative
gold
industry today miners have become more
organized creating cooperatives to hunt
for gold
collectively one such Cooperative is
kopa that was founded in 2008 by former
saalo Banker Gilson
Cambo he takes us for a tour of the Copa
gold mines that are under his
supervision
such gold mines are legal as part of the
Brazilian government strategy to
monetize the
[Music]
Amazon but drone images reveal the
damage to the
environment this was once a lush green
forest with LA and fora spread all
across the
landscape it's been replaced by energy
guzzling
machines
goopa G alone has deforested 3,000
square km of Amazon rainforest since
2008 gold mining in the Amazon
rainforest is attractive for the high
yield of
gold on average the concentration of
gold is 0.5 G for every 1 ton of
soil
inside the Amazon the yield is much
[Music]
higher
gold is found underground after top soil
is
removed once a 10 m ditch is ready the
miners at kopa villagers from rural
Brazil get to
work
a hydraulic machine is parked near the
edge of this vast mining pit that's been
carved into the rainforest reddish Brown
Earth hundreds of gallons of mud sludge
produced by the miners is passed over
carpets with the hope that goldf flakes
stick to
it the carpet is then washed into drums
and the mud is taken to the final
[Music]
process after extensive
panning Mercury is used to extract gold
from the mud through a process called
amalgamation
yeah the crew at kopaja work without
protective
equipment or procedures to help them
discard the Mercury
safely the amalgam of mercury and gold
goes through the final process
[Music]
the heat applied evaporates the Mercury
and gold is left in the
[Music]
pan
Copa mined 400 g of gold
today this is distributed equally
amongst everyone at the mine it will
sell for
$500 in the poor Countryside that's a
fortune for a day's hard
labor
[Music]
for
the raw gold is sold to shops in the
city who process it into gold
bars the final product is exported to to
countries across Asia the Middle East in
America earning billions of dollars in
revenue for the
government Minds like kopaj are legal
and all part of President bolsonaro's
master plan to monetize the
Amazon
but what about the
Amazon on the ground the Damage Done by
legal Minds is
[Music]
irreversible
by law Copa is supposed to restore the
forests once the mine is
closed so Gilson takes us to a restored
part of the
Mind he's turned one area into a fish
farm while planting trees in
[Music]
another
for
as greed takes over concern for the
environment many miners are going for
the big bucks by starting their own
minds deep inside protected territories
away from the
authorities after the break we dig deep
into illegal Mining and meet the people
whose lands have been invaded in the
protected forests of
[Music]
Brazil Brazil's Amazon rainforest is one
of the planet's best defenses against
climate
change it absorbs billions of tons of
carbon
dioxide but deforestation for logging
Mining and for farming crops and
livestock has devastated
it in the last 10 years the rain Forest
has lost an area the size of 8.4 million
soccer
fields but the mining companies want to
use indigenous lands to expand
operations and make more
profits they're pushing for a change in
Brazilian law allowing firms to mine
inside protected lands and Indigenous
reserves Across the
Nation
for despite desite having protected
status indigenous territories are
already facing an
invasion in par State alone Brazilian
authorities estimate that 30 metric tons
of illegal gold worth about 1.1 billion
US has been
excavated that's six times more than the
legal amount of gold traded in
Brazil
this mining boom could lead to the
extinction of indigenous communities
that have weathered centuries of
calamities in Brazil's
rainforest roughly 900,000 indigenous
people live in Brazil Less Than Zero .5%
of the
population they belong to 400 tribes and
speak more than 270
languages one such tribe facing illegal
mining in their protected areas are the
munduruku we travel 16 hours to the city
of bubur
so we're on the tapa River in par State
and we're heading to the mundu lands
indigenous protected lands by the
Brazilian government that have been
invaded by illegal gold miners and we're
going to meet the chief of the tribe to
understand the extent of the
[Music]
problem
Y harez is the chief of the munduruku
tribe he leads nearly 14,000 members who
have splintered into dozens of small
villages scattered across a territory
slightly larger than
3,360 soccer
fields they've lived here for thousands
of
years
fore
that's why huarez has to create borders
or more commonly known as demarcations
to identify his tribe's indigenous
lands motivated by the surging
International price of gold miners
choose to prospect for gold and
protected reserves to evade
taxes it's estimated that nearly 50,000
illegal miners are working inside par
State
[Music]
alone
fore
foree
[Music]
spee
permanently evicting indigenous people
from their land is forbidden under
article 231 of Brazil's
Constitution but the bolsonaro
government is planning to build dams and
INF infrastructure in the tapos River
Basin to boost the
economy armed with machetes Warz and his
crew ensure the conservation of
178,000 hectares of Amazon
rainforest
garez takes us to one such illegal
mining site an hours Boat Ride On the
tapos
River as we arrive we spot a mining
transport
truck we tread carefully as most miners
are armed and do not like
visitors miners in protected areas such
as this excavate land deep inside the
forests away from the authorities
keeping clear of any
inspections
[Music]
fore
as we reach an abandoned mining
pit the extent of the devastation can
only be gauged from high
above kilometers of protected Amazon
rainforest are now mere
ditches
[Music]
spee
we don't venture too far we've been
warned that the illegal miners may open
fire five tribal leaders have already
lost their lives in this
battle but with little enforcement of
the law the destruction
[Music]
continues
for a map published by an NGO shows
illegal mining sites in 37 indigenous
territories in total nearly 2,300
illegal mining sites with sophisticated
infrastructure have been found in
protected
areas harez fears for his life and his
community currently in Brazil mining on
indigenous territories is totally
prohibited the Amazon contains about 20%
of the world's total volume of river
waterer more than 80% of the the world's
food has its origins in this
rainforest apart from tearing down
native forests miners have also started
digging for gold in the rivers
contaminating these waterways with
Mercury we have reports on fishs
dolphins and Indigenous tribes hardly
contaminated by Mercury the
humidity launched by the forest runs in
the atmosphere
and drops like rain all over Brazil
Argentina South America always
connected dredging for gold disrupts
Rivers toxic polluants seep into plants
animals and
people
[Music]
spe
quarez in his community can no longer
fish in the river they have to hunt for
food on land researchers found 92% of
all hair and fish samples collected here
had high levels of mercury resulting in
abnormalities in the central nervous
system of
[Music]
infants so harez has decided to take
things into his own
hands after the break we follow the
munduruku as they plan to invade
Brazil's Congress to pressure
politicians to take
[Music]
action Brazil's president jier bolsonaro
plans to reduce indigenous territories
in the Amazon
[Music]
rainforest the tribes are being
sacrificed to help boost the economy to
create jobs the mining sector is
encroaching into the rainforest and the
hunt for gold has
begun in 2018 Brazil's gold exports
increased
150% on an output of 95
tons with demand Rising miners are
pushing deeper inside protected
forests radically changing the landscape
[Music]
Forever This is why indigenous tribes
have decided to invade the federal
capital
Brazilia Alexandra korab a munduruku
indigenous activist is leading the
charge
Alexandra has arrived in Brazilia the
country's capital to meet her munduruku
[Music]
clan Local Schools been turned into a
makeshift
camp
these 50 munduruku tribals plan to visit
Brazil's Congress to meet
politicians and demand that their land
protected under Brazil law be left
alone
[Music]
according to Brazil's National Institute
for space research in 2018 Alone 5
square kilometers of indigenous
munduruku land was
deforested in 2019 the tree Massacre
increased to 15 Square
km Alexandra believes illegal miners
have the backing of
politicians
[Music]
[Applause]
fore
next day the tribe prepares for battle
they believe bolsonaro's rhetoric has
encouraged the advance of the miners
deeper into indigenous
territory
the munduruku are on their way to
Congress to block a bill that will allow
mining companies to operate inside
indigenous lands
legally it's a key campaign promise of
president bolaro if approved indigenous
tribes in their way of life may be gone
[Music]
forever an economic recession in Brazil
has driven large numbers of unemployed
villages into the jungle to hunt for
gold and the price is being paid by
indigenous
[Music]
people the munduruku arrive at Brazil's
Congress the main legislative body of
the
country this movement is helped by the
country's only indigenous congresswoman
joa
Wana she's only the second indigenous
woman to have ever been elected to
congress
of more than 594 Congress
Representatives only three show
[Music]
up the others celebrate a football
team's participation in a local
[Applause]
[Music]
in a separate chamber Alexandra makes an
impassioned plea for the rights of the
munduruku
[Music]
for
as Brazil is polarized on the issue of
mining in the
Amazon other Industries are coming up
with
[Music]
Solutions luren started pxa a cattle
ranching firm in June
2015 he helped Brazilian Farmers with
sustainable cattle farming
according to the Amazon Institute some
12 million hects of cattle field have
been degraded in the Amazon
region to create new grazing land vast
expanses of the Amazon are
cleared to date an estimated 70% of
deforested Amazon has been converted
into pasture land but paxa offers a
solution
so here we use rotated grazing rotated
grazing means that we have a production
module that has several divisions and
the cattle will stay in one division for
just a few days and then goes to the
other one and then to the other one and
while the cattle does all this cycle
then the first one is
resting this
allows first uh the the fact that the
cattle always has access to the best
part of the plant only the leaves doing
a efficient production we don't need uh
anymore to clear any more land many big
corporations uh over the world have made
commitments to
remove deforestation from the supply
chains from 2010 to 2017 Brazil's beef
exports climbed 25% to 1.5 million tons
with Hong Kong importing the
most to accommodate Global beef demand
cattle ranchers are driving their herds
deeper into the Amazon
rainforest but since operations began in
ALA Floresta paxa has restored 10,000
hectares of pasture
land it now runs 20 Farms that
sustainably manage cattle 34,000 head in
201 17
alone for Lon Reinventing cattle feed
was another necessity of the hour
methane emitted by livestock accounts
for about
5.5% of worldwide greenhouse
gases greenhouse gases that increase
global
temperatures when they have this poor
diet only based on pasture and a low
quality pasture then they have a lot of
production of methan when we do the
reform of the pastures and then we enter
with this
supplement uh we change the diet of the
the animals so we have two benefits one
is to reduce by more or less 40% the
amount of methan that is emitted by The
Animals so when you consider the methan
of the animals and also the carbon from
the soil all together we reduce the
emissions by 90%
[Music]
today the deforestation in the Amazon
claims an area the size of two football
fields a minute if consumption patterns
don't change 50% of the Amazon may
vanish by
2030 destroying one of the world's
largest carbon sinks protecting existing
rainforests and aggressively planting
new ones may be the only way forward and
perhaps one of the last few ways to help
save this planet and all who call it
[Music]
home
Pakistan's Himalayan glazers are melting
at the fastest rate in human
history nearly 36% of its ice sheet will
be gone by
2100 in a battle for water and Kashmir a
nuclear flash point between India and
Pakistan
impacting the water needs of more than
two billion people in South
Asia with Rising heat waves in mega
cities increasing water consumption
communities are fighting over dwindling
supplies basically we're inside illegal
theft
area
dister I don't think many pakistanis
know how bad it
is could an ambitious tree planting
Drive save the melting glazes so we want
to restore 10 lakh hectares in
Pakistan
[Music]
karaji Pakistan's largest city with a
population of 20 million the economic
nerve center of the country is brought
to a
standstill a severe heat wave strikes
the southern Port City in June
2015 with temperatures as high as 49°
C the blazing sun causes total Mayhem
unaware and unprepared more than 2,000
people across Karachi perish from
dehydration and heat
stroke hospitals are ill equipped to
deal with such a
Calamity the Abasi Shahed Hospital Mory
runs out of
space as a result Mass graves are dug to
dispose off the
bodies
[Music]
memories of 2015 have come back to haunt
Karachi
today in 2019 the heat wve has returned
with average daytime temperatures
hitting
49° the synth government declares a
Citywide
emergency we head out to the Abasi
Shahed Hospital's heat stroke unit
to our surprise there are no heatstroke
patients
today 2015 16
to
aess
Karachi government officials are also
better prepared mobile units equipped
with water sprays are deployed
strategically during the hotter hours of
the
day despite the 49° temperature today no
casualties are
reported
This Is The New Normal in
Karachi an international climate report
puts Pakistan at number six on the list
of top 10 countries most affected by
climate
change and in mega cities like Karachi
lack of trees miles of asphalt roads and
tall buildings have increased heat
absorption making matters worse is an
unchecked growing population in poorly
planed yet densely populated
[Music]
settlements Karachi U is a spectacular
example of population explosion it was a
small coastal city which became the
capital city and it is now the largest
city so population you have more people
you need more water you more shops and
factories you need more also
mismanagement Karachi did not manage to
protect its water
courses with Rising temperatures the
massive population of Karachi consumes
more
water Karachi needs 1.1 billion gallons
daily to supply water to roughly 20
million
residents but the water board the city's
Water distributor is only able to
provide 550 million gallons per
day Muhammad Arif is a resident of
kurangi his tap Runs
[Music]
Dry broken water distribution lines
multiply the problem for karachiites
at 2 a.m. Arif arrives at the main
distribution pipeline of the government
100 m from his
home he plans to divert water to his
home with the aid of hoses and a
handheld
motor
there are nearly a million people in
this neighborhood of kurangi
alone and everyone's
thirsty
[Music]
Maxim so what does the Water Board
karachi's Water distributor have to
say basically
transmission
as water becomes rare and difficult to
access a black market is thriving
according to the Karachi water and
sewage board 42% of water is lost in
distribution before reaching
consumers so where does all this water
go we go in search of karachi's water
Thieves for an answer to this
question after much deliberation we
finally convince a water Thief to take
us to his theft point point we film the
process
secretly going and we're going to film
[Music]
this
we're inside legal um sft area this is
our water is Ping in
Kari the water Thief takes us to a
congested
slum in the meantime The Mastermind
arrives to explain how it
works
connection
for
per month per month per month
he takes us to where he steals the water
from water that he then sells at
exorbitant rates while govern government
officials get their
[Music]
cut be
demand dep
theft corruption and disrepair hamper
water access for millions in Pakistan's
largest city it costs millions of
dollars in losses to the National ex
cheer this stolen water is diverted from
the poor to the rich who can pay more a
short-term solution the city developed
for its water needs were water tankers
that now control much of karachi's water
water
distribution more than 10,000 tankers
operate in the city under government
control making an estimated 50,000
delivery trips to Consumers across
Karachi each
day but with few checks and balances
excessive bribes kick in when heat waves
hit
Karachi allowing tanker drivers to jack
up rates as they
will delivery of a 1,000g water tanker
now costs between 12 and $18 per trip
this is a steep price especially for
larger poorer families who spend a third
of their income on Stolen
water a global study projects that
nearly 5 billion people will live in
water stress regions by
2050 while the United Nations estimate
that water shortages can displace
hundreds of millions of people as early
as
2030 water is a massive political issue
in Karachi and Corruption is in the
middle of it
all with one political party depriving
the water needs of another party's
constituency it is a b
reality
disaster
Kar
it's economic
hces and it is really
alarming while solving karachi's Water
Crisis seems like a distance pipe dream
the residents of Karachi are left with
no option but to buy stolen
[Music]
water after the break we embed with the
Karachi water task force in their
efforts to stop water
theft
Karachi Pakistan's largest city has an
epidemic to capitalize on climate change
related water shortages karachi's black
market for water is
thriving millions of dollars worth of
government water is being stolen and
sold to people who can pay a premium so
the Karachi water board has stepped up
their
efforts Chief security officer tabish
razza heads the task force against water
theft
[Music]
inform
as soon as we reach the location the
thieves are spotted and the raid
begins
bu
for
[Music]
a water motor is confiscated in the raid
as tabish explains the kind of money
Changing Hands in karachi's illegal
water
industry
tabish has received another tip off from
a neighboring town a textile Factory is
stealing and reselling
[Music]
water
Factory
looming legal pump from the bo is taken
out and
confiscated this is a daily routine for
tabish and his team they arrest the
perpetrators and Destroy 10 pumps a
day but in a city of 20 million people
and with limited resources the Karachi
water board can only play catchup with
the
thieves and climate change will only
worsen corrupt water
WS climate change will mean more floods
it will mean more
droughts it will mean uh heat waves like
the one we saw in Karachi two years ago
it will mean reduction in the quantity
and reduction in the quality of water
both are serious there will be
significant Health
impacts soaring temperatures in South
Asia are reaching Peak levels due to to
Rising greenhouse gas emissions the heat
is melting the water wall of South Asia
the Himalayas that Supply water to the
rest of the
subcontinent the glazers in Northern
Pakistan in the disputed region of
Kashmir are the biggest ice sheets
outside the polar regions these ice
sheets are
melting we drive 15 hours from Islam
Abad to gulmit a village in Northern par
kastan to investigate its
impact according to a new study 36% of
the glazers found in the region will be
gone by
2100 satara Parvin is a glazi olist who
has studied these ice sheets for a
decade this was once the area which had
plenty of water from this Glacier
because the glacier was much higher and
even up to the level of this morines you
can see here this morine it shows that
the the level was much higher so the
water was uh recharging these uh
irrigation channels the Glaciers are
very sensitive to climate they act
according to the temperature and the
precipitation when it's hot it melts a
lot since 1988 the Snow Line in Northern
Pakistan has receded by 1.1 km
what scientists and glazi olist thought
wasn't possible in 1,000 years has
happened within
30 if Global emissions stay at current
levels future Generations may never see
ice in South
Asia these Glaciers are also important
for these farmers who are living here
who depend on these agricultural for
their livelihoods because you can see
this uh the this is very moistured
deficit area less rainfall in these
plain areas where uh this GL the people
uh practice agriculture so it's not
possible without the water from these
glaciers nestled in the karakorum
mountains as high as 23,000 ft Village
communities like these are
vulnerable welcome welcome welcome we
welcome you to today we welcome you
today we welcome you Lakes forming
within the glazers often burst causing
flash floods destroying life and
property
[Music]
Downstream shaad Al a local resident in
tour guide takes us to the gulen
Glazier due to pollution fine particles
of black carbon are deposited onto White
speeding up the melting
[Music]
process
after a 3-hour trek over ice we arrive
at the gulan Glazier one of the largest
in Northern
Pakistan streams of water run down into
the
crevices collecting at the bottom of the
Glazier as the sun blazes onto the ice
sheet
shaut points out this water collects
into a massive Lake within the Glazier
that can burst any time and flood the
village
Downstream
in June 2019 a glacial Lake formed in
the neighboring shisa Glazier that
forced the government to react local
officials hurriedly built a concrete
wall to prevent the water from bursting
the
banks but they stood no chance in front
of the Savage War of water that came
hurtling down at the
Village Tark remembers that fateful
day
tar believes more than 30 homes were
washed away and if proper planning was
done they could have been
saved uh
80% as it is Conant 20%
200t 200t is
nothing tar takes us to the shis Glazier
he believes it's the next disaster in
the
making this black Glazier is physically
moving 5 to 6 M A Day Downstream to the
Village due to Rising temperatures and
local communities are concerned if it's
going to destroy homes
again
the region is expected to face Mass
Water shortages in around 50 years when
glazers become too
small after the break we take you to the
highest militarized Zone in the
world where India and Pakistan are
battling a war on top of a
glazier Pakistan has been bestowed with
five of the biggest rivers in the world
the mighty indis jalum chinab Ravi and
sulet that have cascaded down the plains
of the PJ for hundreds of
years these rivers are formed by melting
glazers in the karakorum and Himalayan
ranges one such Glazier is nestled
between India and Pakistan in the
Eastern karakorum range in the
Himalayas it's called the siin Glazier
and is claimed in full by both Pakistan
and
India it's been disputed territory after
after the two countries split in
1947 the contended area is a sheet of
ice nearly 1,000 square mil in
total unable to settle the land dispute
diplomatically troops were amassed on
top of the Glazier by both
countries Pakistan and India have spent
millions of dollars a month to keep
troops posted
here and 6,700 M it is the highest
militarized Zone in the
world the dispute over land between
India and Pakistan transcends
Downstream to the waters that continue
to flow from India to
Pakistan after partition in
1947 India and Pakistan were unsure of
how to share water hence the Indus water
treaty was signed in 1960 between then
Indian prime minister Minister jawahar L
Neu and Pakistani president Ayub Khan in
Karachi brokered by the World Bank the
treaty allowed both countries to use the
water available in the indust system of
rivers the two countries because of
historic problems and animosity and
hostility could not agree on joint
management so it was considered that a
second
partition should take place
Pakistan got the rights to use the three
Western Rivers the indas jalm and tab
exclusively while India won the rights
to use the three Eastern Rivers the Ravi
sutle and
Bas but today tensions between the
nuclear neighbors over Kashmir is
putting pressure on this water treaty
the Hindu nationalist BJP led by Prime
Minister Modi has rattled things Modi
now wants to build dams to block the
flow of water into
Pakistan making the Indus River a hot
spot that might escalate into a nuclear
[Music]
war I think the next fight would be on
water actually the world is going to
fight on a water and we never realized
indust water treaty when it was done in'
70s that was the time that we could
solve this problem but India always more
authoritative never obey the rules even
if they are Internationals so this
treaty remained what would I say it it
remained just in the
books Pakistan's semiarid climate means
more than 90% of harvests depend on
irrigation you're going to have
pakistanis receiving less
water so when you receive less water you
blame the supplier so there is a
potential uh uh source of conflict and
the Secretary General in his report the
UN Secretary General made a specific
reference to India and Pakistan and said
that climate change is likely to put
pressure on the endus water treaty which
has served the two
countries well for almost 60
years
despite four full-blown Wars India and
Pakistan have never had a water War but
the situation in the disputed region of
Kashmir is
escalating a majority of Pakistan's
Rivers originate from Indian
administered Kashmir and in August 2019
India did the
unthinkable India's dams released nearly
6 million liters of water per second
into Pakistan without
intimation the Pakistani province of
Punjab was flooded drowning hundreds of
Acres of agricultural land Islamabad
reacted angrily it claimed this
unexpected release of water into the
river sutl that flows from India to
Pakistan was part of an attempt by New
Delhi to flout the Indus water
treaty this was followed by the
revocation of article 370 in 2019 to
eliminate the special status of Indian
administered Kashmir an area claimed by
[Music]
Pakistan
as geopolitical realities mix with a
potential water War the reaction in
Pakistan administered Kashmir is
[Music]
intense we travel to Pakistan controlled
Kashmir at the Frontline of this complex
battle where tempers are reaching
boiling
point
gilan Kashmir
jamu or
Kashmir
[Applause]
such rallies in Pakistan administered
have become
routine frequent protests are putting
pressure on the Pakistani army to
liberate Indian administered Kashmir and
secure the supply of water for Mainland
Pakistan as
[Music]
well
k
the government of Pakistan administered
Kashmir fears that Prime Minister Modi
May usurp the Indus water treaty and
leave Pakistan in a drought-like
situation in a never-ending conflict
between two nuclear armed countries more
than 50,000 kashmiris have lost their
lives will the water dispute claim
more
after the break we look at Prime
Minister Imran Khan's billion tree
tsunami that's being built as the idea
that could save the
region December
2019 New Delhi is in the grips of an
intense
smog the air quality index reads as high
as
1,000 the smog transcends the Border
over to parts of
Pakistan a Blame Game erupts between
politicians on either side of the
Border it never stopped its uh kissan to
to BN the rice husk it never stopped it
people for the or the BTA mazour for a
brick kills next time through our
foreign Ministry for this Kashmir issue
or for any bilateral talk third agenda
should be this smoke and all this
pollution
between India and Pakistan and again I'm
saying Pakistan has done a lot India has
not NASA satellite data shows a heavy
concentration of fires on the Indian
side and far fewer on the Pakistani side
of the
border the end result was a deadly Smog
and downgrading of air quality across
the subcontinent particularly in
India cricket star turned prime minister
Imran Khan's surprising respon
grabbed
headlines his party the Pakistan T insaf
spearheaded billion tree tsunami in 2014
at a cost of $169
million this was the Pakistani
government's response to the challenge
of global warming in South Asia Pakistan
has the lowest tree cover in the region
giving it more reason to reforest a
billion trees were planted from 2014 to
but prime minister Khan isn't stopping
here he has vowed to plant 10 billion
trees in the next 5 years of his
government 10 billion tree tsunami but
before that it was actually billion tree
tsunami uh it was started by the Prime
Minister Imran Khan at that time he was
not a prime minister and we had a one
Province government that was called kpk
this was the first green initiative that
our country started in 73 years it was
one of of the different and the finest
um project that any government on
provincial level started so it was
billion Tre
tsunami and it has made the marks on the
on the history on the
world the plan is to increase the forest
cover in the country and attract rains
that will reduce Rising
temperatures in total Pakistan has
restored 350,000 hectares of forest and
deg graded land to surpass its Bond
challenge
commitment Pakistan's Vision 2025 is
aiming to work on better Water
Management as well due to traditional
farming techniques 2/3 of irrigation
water is lost through system leakages
across the
country that's why farmers like Asik
bangash have stepped in a resident of
Islamabad bangash decided to introduce
strip IR a into Pakistan's traditional
farming
system to save the time and uh water and
uh to give water to the plants up to the
standard requirement not less not
excess
Pakistan is among the six countries that
will be most affected by global warming
and a rising population calls for
measures to protect natural
resources
government
system DP irrigation solar system or
high
shed 2025 has been marked as the year
when Pakistan may turn into a water
scarce country unable to meet its water
needs existing Reservoir storage
capacity cannot sustain Pakistan's
population boom while riverflow has also
been reduced over the
years Pakistan can get more economic
social and environmental benefits from
better water use
but it's subject to continuous reforms
to improve water use efficiency and
Service delivery and create awareness
among the general
[Music]
public in laor pakistanis are rising to
the challenge to put pressure on
politicians across Pakistan to do
more
people don't understand how bad it is
there are just this year there were
floods uh unexpected rains in Punjab
that wiped out a substantial portion of
the wheat crop and that affected
people's livelihoods and for a country
where a quarter of the population is at
or near the poverty line a single event
like that one rain is the difference
between getting a a square meal a day or
not in a country Bes set with problems
only 4% think that climate change is an
issue
RAF wants to change this
attitude he's taking his family to The
Climate march to raise awareness amongst
kids in
Pakistan okay so you're going to be
leading the March no we're going to be
helping organize it the children who are
organ leading the March students not us
so please
responsive it's
safer paper and pen
all right so we've got March and miali
currently under um
progress the Youth of Pakistan are
concerned about their future when the
impact of climate change May
worsen and it's been
spectacular
[Music]
partip
more than 5,000 marches take place
worldwide along with Lao on the same
day the climate strike is the largest
ever Collective call to action in the
world my government is the biggest
polluter in history and should be doing
something about it but instead president
Trump doesn't even believe in climate
change and wants to pull us out of the
Paris agreement I find it completely
unacceptable especially because my
friends and in-laws here in Pakistan are
the ones who are already suffering the
most from the impacts of climate
[Music]
change
Pakistan contributes less than 1% of the
world's greenhouse gases yet it is the
world's sixth most vulnerable country
affected by climate
change while it must develop a robust
foreign policy that allows it to
effectively negotiate climate issues
with its neighbors Pakistan's march to
solve its climate problems has
[Music]
begun
e